Okay, so what we're going to do intuitively is
we're going to add a new vertex to the graph, and then we're going to add an edge
from all of the current vertices in the graph to the new  vertex.
And then we're simply going to return the result
of graph is 4colorable of this new graph.
So we construct a new graph, which is just an empty list in this case,
and then for every node in the original graph, we add in an additional 1.
Since this is an adjacency matrix, that means that there is an additional vertex
that every single node in this graph is connected to, like I just said.
We're going to append this new node to  each row in the adjacency matrix.
Then, we're going to append a column of 1's at the end of this graph
of the adjacency matrix, and this represents the vertex that is connected to
every other vertex, which is what we've just constructed.
And then we take this new graph, and we simply run it through graph is 4colorable.
So we've reduced the 3colorable problem to the 4colorable problem.
And, by the definition of NP completeness, that means that the 4colorable problem
is also NP-complete.